vamos a hablar más de estas
declaraciones del presidente ruso
vladimir putin que podemos destacar y
hablarnos también del ambiente en ese
concierto
pues ha sido un ambiente eminentemente
patriótico hay que recordar que se trata
de un aniversario muy importante para
los rusos porque en aquel 2014 entonces
sí que sirvió para aumentar la
popularidad de vladimir putin en rusia
la anexión de crimea parece que el
presidente ruso busca un boost similar
en este caso después de haber comenzado
durante el mes de febrero esa llamada
operación especial en ucrania el
presidente ruso se está ahora
concentrando en conectar con la opinión
pública agravando los esfuerzos
patrióticos de las tropas rusas en
ucrania que como ha recordado vladimir
putin están
intentando evitar un genocidio entre la
población rusa presidente en el país
vecino putin ha lavado a sus soldados
sólo unos días después de haber
advertido contra los llamados
quintacolumnistas es decir todos
aquellos rusos que por una razón por
otra no solo no están de acuerdo con
esta llamada operación militar especial
sino que además se han atrevido a
decirlo públicamente a ellos los ha
señalado diciendo que
aunque algunos vivan aquí en rusia y no
hayan conseguido vivir fuera su mente
está fuera de este país y no conectan
este es el ambiente que hay ahora mismo
en rusia conectando precisamente con ese
espíritu patriótico que trata de
recuperar vladimir putin